yeah okay so first of all I want to say
yeah just thank you so much to the
Academy for having us here it's a crazy
thing to say but really it's I mean it
really it's been so amazing the last few
days meeting the people from the Academy
and your amazing careers in that you saw
our film and voted it's it's truly an
honor
big honor so thank you so much I want to
thank everyone who worked on the film
obviously first of all my amazing
producer Rebecca thank you for for the
great ambition you had for the film and
for believing it everything you did it's
amazing and my cinematographer talking
us for being the best creative partner
and for being such an amazing
photographer and friend and everything
and my editor has been the sound guys
Hansen lost that did such an amazing job
they're so incredibly talented and it's
been an honor working with them I want
to take my actors my tasks who is just
incredible I live have you I'm brie and
of course anata that did the lead role
like she carries this whole film on her
shoulders and did such an amazing job
and seeing like a script come to life
like that it's just been incredible my
school of course I also want to thank
them and and really everyone that was a
part of making this film it's sometimes
it's crazy that even happens you know
from from like yeah the guy in the
middle of Norway that had a dentist one
in his freezer or two like yeah yeah the
costume designer is family that length
of the cabin it's just favors like that
that makes it possible so thank you so
so so much yeah yeah a special thank to
teachers and mentors life and faith
which is here today we that really means
a lot to us and of course also the other
winners
it's been so great to get to know you
and it's so inspiring to see all of your
projects and we can't wait to see what
you do next and hopefully we get maybe
we can work together sometime and on
behalf of the whole production we really
want to thank Eddy care for this great
script and you're such a great person
you're such a talented girl and we yeah
I'm really really good
[Laughter]
[Applause]